you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman leeches org
and going to play a five Oh came so
let's see what we get here already
how about well well let's mix it up
instead of a Rai Lopez let's go with the
Scotch opening don't play this too much
let's take and let's play Bishop to d3
on d5 I need to take pushing Knight g4
so let's see castles yeah let's go with
castles Queen H R Queen to f3 maybe
usually the bishop plays here now these
are squares I could try to control and
here to here combined with the bishop
hmm let's start with this it's useful
flight square much more long-term but I
want to play Queen to f3 maybe even get
a light square bishop exchange although
I'd really like to have a dark square
bishop exchange and control over the g5
and d4 squares
rook b8 is pretty normal even seen rook
b8 and then the rook b4 pivot let's see
rook they're not here let's try this
let's give it a shot
nights before bishops is what they say
huh a really big fan of that I prefer
the
the line moved the piece with the fewest
possibilities first which usually means
nights before bishops anyhow I can't
move my dark square bishop until I
defend bee
play b3 my nights and now unprotected
state let's do that thinking about night
here are they going to go up Bishop b7
and look for this maybe you know that
maybe is an idea what would I do on that
I don't know maybe Knight a 4 and this
d4 push bit annoying maybe they play d4
right now
now d4 I'll jump right in Bishop b7 I
could take with check if this pawn is
here with the Knights off the board I'm
fine with that but Knights on the board
with the pawn here I have to worry about
95 and Knight c3 some stage I know just
feel like if the pawn is on d4 and the
Knights are exchanged it's better for me
well I don't know better but I'd feel a
little bitty I'd feel a little bit more
comfortable I really gotten they really
went into the think tank on this one are
they trying to make some magic happen
against this guy Oh
all right let's develop what's tempo
definitely so now okay they seem to be a
bit hesitant with playing with the
hanging pawn structure okay well let's
not be so quick to help them develop
let's challenge this rook yeah let's do
this
I am I really like the dark square
bishop exchange long term King's off the
board gore excuse me Queen
you know let's play his position with
the Kings off the board who needs them
yeah with the Queen's off the board
ideally I'd like to have a dark square
block hate a knight on c5 King on d4
slowly improve my position my pony will
be on their heels
you know we're also down with clock love
it I love that it's my opponent not me
all right night go to a safe square
maybe see four are they going to play
see five I think see five is a good idea
if they're not careful I may take and
then play Queen here okay that was a
very important moment very important
moment okay rook here they can't feel
too comfortable about the rook being
opposite third Queen
I was thinking and see for that I have
to take my knight would be unprotected
in that case but I don't have to take
like a tickle it I could I don't have to
take with the phone I could take with
the bishop I think their queen is more
inconvenience than my own they are
really using a lot of fuel here buck
thirty and a five oh and doubled up okay
well with this clock situation I'm
always thinking of as a last resort I
have time burning tactics don't think
like that man win by position yeah it's
one of my thoughts figured I'd share it
alright so let's get serious now it's
time to get serious
Bishop takes Queen takes how can I take
advantage of the Queen's position I
don't know my knight feels a little
stranded I'm being honest for a moment I
thought maybe I should have played rippy
1 instead of b3 and then try it for b4
to get a grip over c5 anyhow I'm hanging
pawn structure let's take that for
starters
I don't want to play c4 because that
gives them a pass pawn
let's go for a bishop trade yeah let's
see what they do they're tied down their
queen has a job that she is not a fan of
I can assure you rook okay
now their queen is overloaded let's go
quick Knight takes pawn is now a threat
the Queen has two jobs and two jobs is
too many alright so what about c3 hmm no
no no no let's get on this same file
excuse me diagonal as their King and
throw a punch here this is maybe an idea
okay let's keep my Queen in this good
spot they caught up some on the clock
hmm I could play Queen here and let's do
that actually
Queenie five alright so we have this
ending don't we I keep this closed yeah
let's do this get my King towards the
center soon their Knight can't move so
easily um wow that moe how Knight c5
right now
I should get my king over my rook does a
good job of restricting their Knight are
they going to push on push I may just
take a step with my king
I don't want to open up the position the
file I should say okay let's see he
could turn out to be a upon that could
easily drop scoop him up there night's
going to get active I imagine I need to
secure my king position I want the
Knights off the board and it's going to
be a big race who's going to win what is
most important this pawn I'm not fearing
him anymore I want to get the a pawn and
then push my beep on to victory line
mm-hmm now improve your knight position
Knight fork right here as well the pawn
is pinned I'm going to take that on
definitely going to take let's play here
hmmm let's insert this check mmm another
check
let's check and push push again and
promote let's just got here and throw a
punch get the Queen really what's that
about
four seconds is what it's about
hmm don't have any time oh I'm down in
time man they caught back up on time and
wasn't I talking about out time burners
they're the one who ended up hitting me
with time burners they caught up on the
clock
ah man oh well let's go into the
analysis I think I had the right idea
with hunting down there upon the h-bomb
in that ending in that rook and night
ending I happy with how I played of
course wouldn't have liked to have lost
on time at the end but it's a close one
could have very easily been my opponent
we lost on time and that one but hmm
let's see
okay so scotch it's certainly a little
bit different not don't have too much
experience with this opening
let's see cleanup three rookie a look
there yeah I didn't mention this idea
maybe be for no I don't know about that
it's going to still take a it's still
going to take some time to get in be for
that doesn't seem like the right idea of
III have to be a bit careful
v3 loose peace can it be taken advantage
of I liked seeing c6 because I get to
develop its tempo even even even even
and it remains even close game and this
is where things will change some or not
it's still an even game yeah even right
down to the and really I mean this is
where we were about the in bullet mode
for sure and this is an important moment
because I it does like rook to the
seventh and you know I was tempted to
still be in it I was tempted to keep
this mentality of let's get that seep on
he's a liability but what's most
important here is to see it as these two
versus this one what is stopping me from
acquiring a passed pawn get this guy
activate your rook and I was ready to
also do this move which mmm I don't know
what do you say Knight on c5 and my my
rook I want to keep him on the seventh
rank let's say and by playing here I'm
improving my Knights position for the
moment okay I only has it as a slight
edge and yeah after a five it's probably
just winning from here for white they
needed to do something else
passive but I don't even know if that
that could be recommended but maybe it
really is that important because if
you're just grabbing here I don't know
black is just so far off from acquiring
a passed pawn take two connected passed
pawns
I'm already controlling the cleaning
square black would be pretty lucky to uh
to hold this to a draw I don't really
see that in the UH in the future for
black here with these two guys
so yeah and you know what that's you
know black realized you know well
actually why did they go with that oh
that's why they wanted to defend the
pawn in a way which stopped me from
adding an additional attacker to it so
if they're doing this I could come over
and he will be one so I guess at this
stage they were black did not want to
just go into a completely defensive
posture instead figured let's pitch upon
and break up these guys but he's passed
in the end his floundering some around
here checks get pushing and yeah okay
yeah they were being sneaky they're not
immediately taking the Queen and instead
going for this time burner strategy but
uh yeah they take there to defend take
care there excuse me defend here well
okay well as usual um yeah I don't think
there are very many games with me
playing the Scotch opening bata yeah
anyhow I hope you're able to take
something away from this video as usual
feel free to leave any comments in the
comment section below and yeah hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye